en 1913 le grand mathématicien jean
croire dit alors professeur à cambridge
reçu une lettre d'un hymne plus 1e crack
prétendant avoir découvert des théorèmes
révolutionnaire j'en ai reçu m'a même la
plupart du temps c'est subtilement faut
ou pas si novateur mais ce que vit a
redit le stupéfia l'une des équations
qui le laisse à bolbec et l1 kreab
égalité 1 + 2 + 3 + cats jusqu'à
l'infini est égal à - 1 12e n'importe
quel mathématicien digne de ce nom
aurait éclaté de rire et immédiatement
jeté la lettre à la poubelle et en effet
le professeur il un mathématicien
contemporain de radecki reçu une lettre
similaire a souligné la stupidité de
l'auteur de la lettre mes ordis lui
n'était pas n'importe quel mathématicien
plutôt que d'y voir une absurdité source
de moquerie ordi y voyait un éclair de
génie cette équation
combiné aux nombreuses autres égalité
stupéfiante de la lettre le laissa sans
voix les cris vie ces formules m'avait
complètement vaincu je n'avais jamais
rien vu qui n'en arrive à la cheville
un seul coup d'oeil était suffisant pour
me convaincre qu'elle ne pouvait avoir
été écrite que par un mathématicien de
la plus grande classe
elle devait être juste car personne ne
pouvait
imagination de l'est sans doute et hardy
semblait convaincu de la véracité de 1
plus de plus rock plus 4 jusqu'à
l'infini également un deuxième c'est que
cette équation cash bel et bien quelque
chose qui semble dépasser la plupart
d'entre nous cette équation étrange vous
l'avez peut-être déjà vu ailleurs
puisque plusieurs vidéos youtube semble
l'a démontré à coups de super sommation
line est régulière et stable
le genre de super sommation que l'on a
utilisé dans l'épisode précédent
sauf que sauf que ceux d'entre vous qui
ont le courage de regarder l'épisode
hardcore de jeudi dernier savent que
c'est super mation nine est régulière et
stable des entiers sont pires que archi
fausse
elles sont inconsistantes c'est ce qu'a
prouvé rémy père dans les commentaires
d'un article de science étonnante soit s
la somme des entiers positif alors
est-ce moins deux aces plus s est égale
à la somme un plus zéro plus zéro plus
zéro plusieurs qui est donc égale 1 1
mais est-ce moins deux fps c'est aussi
égale à zéro s qui est égal à zéro
du coup un est égal à zéro
vous comprenez ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que s'il existe une super
sommation et linéaire régulière et
stable des entiers alors un égal 0
autrement dit on à un cataclysme
mathématiques ce qu'a fait rémy père est
dévastateur il a montré en une ligne que
tous les calculs de number five mythe
maths et sciences étonnante était faux
oui les mathématiques sont un domaine où
toute une théorie peut être démoli par
un argument d'une seule ligne
c'est je pense ce qui fait en partie la
beauté des mathématiques et dans
l'histoire des mathématiques
c'est arrivé on en reparlera un certain
frégault s'est fait complètement démolir
par un argument d'une ligne de russell
moi pour ma part j'ai la chance de ne
pas avoir blogué ou de ne pas avoir fait
de vidéo sur ce sujet avant d'avoir lu
les commentaires de rémy père parce que
sinon je serais tombé dans le panneau
comme tous les autres ceci étant dit
s'il est vrai que la somme des antiennes
n'a pas de super sommation linéaire
régulière et stable
il semble néanmoins que l'équation un
plus de plus 3 + câble ainsi de suite
jusqu'à l'infini égal moins un douzième
reste néanmoins vrai et le plus fou
c'est que la preuve la plus convaincante
que j'en connaisse nous vient de la
physique en 1948
le physicien yves roux et casimir fille
la prédiction insensé que le vide avait
de l'énergie
et pas n'importe quelle énergie casimir
à regret que les vibrations stationnaire
entre deux murs avait toute une énergie
proportionnelle à leur fréquence
du coup la vibration de mode un avait
une énergie proportionnelle à 1 celle du
de modeuse avait une énergie
proportionnelle à 2 et ainsi de suite
pour déterminer l'énergie totale des
vibrations kazim rajoute à toutes les
énergies de toutes les vibrations ce qui
le conduisit à une énergie
proportionnelle à ont plus de +3 plus
que la puce 5 et ainsi de suite
cette somme a priori est divergente
infinie mais une énergie infinie en
physique ça n'a aucun sens
casimir aurait sans doute dû rejeter sa
théorie mais il avait défendu dire qu'il
y avait un lien mystérieux entre la
somme des entiers et le nombre - 1 12e
il osa alors exploiter ce lien pour
faire ce qui peut être la prédiction la
plus insensée de toute l'histoire de la
fille
il prédit que l'énergie totale culminait
à - 1 12e fois l'énergie de vibrations
de mode un laquelle est inversement
proportionnel à la distance entre les
plaques en particulier la dérive et de
l'énergie qui correspond à une force est
une force qui attire les plaques et
l'intensité de cette force est
exactement prédite par le calcul était
raisonnable de casimir et le plus fou
c'est qu'en 1997 cette prédiction
insensé de casimir a été confirmée par
l'expérimentation
c'est incroyable non seulement ceux ci
montrent l'existence de l'énergie du
vide ce qui en tant que telle et déjà
stupidement débile mais en plus c'est
similaire que l'étrange égalité 1 plus
de +3 puisqu'elle jusqu'à l'infini gueye
- un douzième à un fond de vérité et ça
c'est pire que des bills n'ont su pid
surtout quand on sait qu'on ne peut pas
déduire cette équation de manipulation
algébrique voilà qui pose un énorme
problème
on sait que la somme des antilles est
égal à - 1 12e mais on ne sait pas
vraiment pourquoi et dans quel sens que
c'est ce qu'affirme edwards frenkel un
grand mathématicien de berkeley dans
cette vidéo de number five
enfin il ya quand même au moins trois
bonnes raisons plus mathématique de
penser que la somme des entier est
effectivement il ya là - 1 12e
malheureusement ces bonnes raisons sont
un peu compliquées du coup je vais pas
pouvoir en parler sur scène sont allés
jure par les soyons fous il faut que
vous préviennent si vous n'avez pas un
bon niveau de lycéens voire niveau
universitaire vous risquez de ne rien
comprendre à la suite
mais même si vous savez que vous risquez
de ne rien comprendre je vous invite
quand même à regarder la suite de cet
épisode pourra essayer de voir la
manière dont les mathématiciens
réfléchissent et essayer de percevoir un
peu la beauté qu'il peut y avoir
derrière tous ces raisonnements et puis
au final ne rien comprendre à un
raisonnement ça c'est le quotidien du
mathématicien donc en fait en écoutant
parler dans les minutes qui viennent si
vous comprenez rien vous vivez ce que
vit un mathématicien au quotidien
commençons par leur régularisation parle
exponentielle de cette série on peut
rajouter un petit terme géométriques à
chaque terme de cette somme infini pour
la rendre convergentes
on obtient alors la gentille sommes
infinie convergentes
un fois option x + 2 fois où tu sens -
2x plus trois fois en france - 3 x et
ainsi de suite
cette somme infinie et gentille car on
peut calculer la valeur exacte même si
c'est un peu technique
remarquant que c'est la semaine des
aides pour l'option semeuse enix qui est
moins la somme des dérivés d'absence -
nxp dallas - la dérivée de la seule
option ce mot enix reconnaît la
géométrie quand on connaît la valeur cet
honneur c'est 1 sur 1 - uhb sciences po
x et donc pas vers l'autre il suffit de
dérivés ce qui me donne moins de
puissance - x / 1 - op sciences po x au
carré pour retrouver la somme d oran
tienne il faut maintenant prendre la
limite de cette expression quand x tend
vers zéro mais la langue de bol quand on
prend x tend vers zéro on voit et on
aurait pu le prédire que toutes ces
expressions tendent vers l'infini mais
bien souvent en mathématiques quand un
truc tu en verras mans vers l'infini on
veut aussi s'intéresser à la manière
dont ça tend vers l'infini donc ont
effectué un développement limité genre
de développement limité dont j'ai parlé
dans l'épisode 3 de la série sur la
relativité générale et quand on cherche
à exprimer ses expressions quand même
temps une somme de puissance de x on
obtient le développement limité
la somme des entier à cette
régularisation prêt est égal à 1 sur x
au carré - un douzième plus petit aux
deux saperlipopette voilà le moins un
12e qui apparaît ou plus précisément à
une erreur divergentes près
sound et entier semble tendre vers -1 12
yens convaincu non moi non plus pourquoi
at on choisi d'utiliser une
régularisation parle exponentielle est
ce qu'on n'aurait pas pu choisir quelque
chose d'autre est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas
obtenu quelque chose d'autre
si on avait choisi une autre règle
réalisation étrangement non si on prend
une autre régularisation et a pourvu
qu'elles satisfassent quelques bonnes
propriétés du genre et à 2 0 est égal à
1 parce qu'on prend la limite théorique
se tend vers zéro et puis on va demander
à ce que l'état soit suffisamment
déférence yable étendent suffisamment
vite vers 0,6 et à a suffisamment de
bonnes propriétés alors le développement
limité de la somme des entiers
régularisés par la fonction et à nous
donne un terme divergents qui dépendent
de la régularisation est à - 1 12e plus
petit taux de 1
encore une fois ce mystérieux - un
douzième apparaît et le fait qu'ils
apparaissent
indépendamment de la régularisation que
l'on a choisi suggère qu'il ya vraiment
un lien profond entre cette somme des
entiers et moins un deuxième c'est quand
même mis sérieusement joli tout ça mais
il ya plus intriguant encore
la deuxième bonne raison à relier aux
probèmes ouvert le plus prestigieux des
mathématiques d'aujourd'hui à savoir
l'hypothèse de riemann ton angie a déjà
parlé dans cette excellente vidéo
en bref l'hypothèse de riemann
s'intéresse à la fonction c'est à deux
aces qui est égale à la somme d 1 sur
une puissance s ou s est un paramètre
qui peut prendre des valeurs complexe
cette fonction est particulièrement
intéressante car elle est intimement
relié à la distribution de nombres
premiers
en effet état de s est aussi le produit
d 1 sur un mois -un sur pépé sans cesse
enfin ça a priori ça ne marche que si
elle a une partie réelle supérieure à 1
toutefois si l'on oublie la manière dont
on la définit on voit que l'état a de
très bonnes propriétés qui nous invite à
la prolonge analytiquement sur quasiment
tout le plan complexe
on peut même prouvé que non seulement ce
prolongement existé mais il est même
unique est bien défini partout sauf en
est ces gars là
de plus on a des formules qui permettent
de relier les points aux états étaient
mal définis au point où elle a été bien
défini par la série somme d 1 sur une
puissance s ceci nous permet de calculer
les valeurs de cette fonction un peu
partout et l'on a par exemple et à 2 - 1
est égal à - 1 12e et si on interprète
maintenant cette formule avec l'équation
aux états de s est égale à la somme d 1
sur un but sans cesse nous tombe à
nouveau tout aussi mystérieusement sur
l'intrigante égalité 1 + 2 + 3 puces
quête jusqu'à l'infini également un
deuxième
et ça ça convainc pas mal de
mathématiciens pas forcément de la
véracité de l'égalité mais au moins du
fait qu'elle cache quelque chose d'
extrêmement profond mais puisqu'il nous
faut maintenant boucler la boucle
revenons-en à rames à nogent
et la troisième bonne raison pour
laquelle la somme des antilles est égal
à monza dossier ramanujan est l'auteur
de la lettre que reçu hardy il est aussi
le héros du film récent l'homme qui
connaissent l infini ramanujan est
partie de l'équation de l'air mclaurin
qui permet d'approximations sous la
courbe d'une fonction par l'histogramme
de la fonction et une correction que
l'on déduit des dérivés aux extrémités
et reste alors une petite erreur mais
ramanujan choisi de négliger cette
erreur ramanujan pris ensuite la limite
de ces expressions grand haine envers
l'infini ce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
qui divergent quant à elle tend vers
l'infini et bien rama nous avons choisi
purement et simplement d'enlever tous
les termes qui dépendent de haine pour
ne s'intéresser qu'à ce qu'il reste
quand les infinies de l'expression sont
supprimés
rama nous on implique a enfin sa formule
mystérieuse à la fonction f2 xt gala x
il fut émerveillé par ce qu il opta ceux
qui le pain c'est encore une fois
l'étrange égalité 1 plus de plus 3 +
cats et ainsi de suite jusqu'à l'infini
également un deuxième
je sais que c'est faux je commence à
croire que c'est vrai lehner fois on a
parlé de la somme des puissances de 2 et
johan albrecht se demande pourquoi
est-ce que j'ai autant insisté sur la
stabilité sur le fait que je pense qu'on
peut vous pourrez tester contre
stabilité et bien j'ai donné la réponse
dans cet épisode c'est parce que
certaines séries divergentes ne peuvent
pas être super semer de façon linéaire
régulière et stable et sans aller jusqu
à l'exemple de cet épisode
alexandre m et thierry costes il
justement montré dans les commentaires
de l'épisode précédent que la somme un
plus un plus un rush du sang jusqu'à
l'infini ne pouvait pas être super semer
de façon linéaire régulière et stable en
effet si on écrit x égale 1-1 puis
simplisme ans jusqu'à l'infini
alors x est égal à un +6 et du coup si
on retranche ix des deux côtés on
obtient 1 0 est égal à 1 et on a une
contradiction
du coup on n'a pas le droit de super
sommet la somme un puissant plus
impuissants ceci étant dit on peut
assigner une valeur à la somme des en
plus en plus impuissants avec les
techniques que l'on a introduit dans
cette vidéo et on trouve alors un plus
un peu stressant jusqu'à l'infini est
égal à -1 2 me oui je sais c'est super
bizarre maintenant ce qu'on peut faire
c'est ajouter la somme un plus de puces
rops cas jusqu'à l'infini à la seule un
plus un plus un jusqu'à l'infini on
obtient la série de puces robe fuschia
jusqu'à l'infini
sauf que les super formation qu'on a vu
dans la cet épisode sur tous les supers
sommation dorama nogent et la super
sommation par régularisation sont des
supers solutions qui sont linéaires du
coup la somme de ces deux séries doit
être égale à la somme de leur valeur ce
qui est égale donc à moins 7 12e et par
ailleurs on sait que un plus et euros +0
plusieurs oscars infinie est égal à 1
du coup cette fois ci on fait la somme
des entier - 1 plusieurs opus zéro plus
zéro n'obtient la série 0 plus de plus
trois opus qui a jusqu'à l'infini
sauf que cette fois la valeur de cette
série et là ça va être moins 1 12e
- 1 ce qui nous fait -13 dossier donc on
voit que les deux séries 2 + 3 plus
calmes jusqu'à l'infini et zéro + 2 opus
3 puisqu'elle jusqu'à l'infini ont des
valeurs différentes
autrement dit la subversion nation doha
main du joueur il a super sommation par
régularisation ne sont pas stables
dernier après l'entropie à pierre
lacombe et michel lambin se sont amusés
à air a effectué le même raisonnement de
que la somme 1 +11 qu'on a vu dans la
vidéo précédente mais cette fois en base
10 n'obtient 9 9 9 avec une infinité de
9 sur la gauche est égale 1 - 1
cette égalité elle est vraie et un troc
à la démontrer avec des supers en
restauration linéaire régulière et
stable et ce raisonnement peut se
généraliser à toutes les bases pour le
prouver
dans le cas général je vous invite à
quelques avec une super sommation ligne
régulière et stable
un peu x + x et au carré +6 occupés
ainsi de suite jusqu'à l'infini pour
tous types différents de 1
et d'ailleurs le résultat que vous allez
trouver est intimement liée au
prolongement analytique de cette série
qui a pris il est fini que sur -1 ou sur
le disque ouvert du pain complexe de riz
noir michel l'amba aurélien roche lord
marelle ont fait le lien entre le calcul
en base de covè fait et ce qui se passe
dans les ordinateurs fait dans un
ordinateur les entiers sont encodées
sous forme de beats et en fait on a une
espace mémoire limitée pour écrire un
entier donc typiquement si vous utilisez
les langages classique de programmation
java ou c++ le nombre de bits utilisée
pour représenter un entier non signé et
égale à 32
du coup on peut écrire avec cela des
noms entre zéro et deux puissances 32 -
en fait de puissance 32 - il va être
représentée par 32 bits qui sont tous
égaux à 1
et si on fait plus 1 à cela et basse à
la sphère 0 et donc en informatique on
utilise beaucoup l'égalité un but sain
les dianes 0 mais on a un nombre fini 2
1 en fait on informatique
on travaille mots
du lot de puissance 32 et le fait que
dans mon exemple en fait il y avait une
infinité de 1 sur la gauche
ça pose problème notamment à hervé
suaudeau mais aussi à baobab eu et
pollux à mort qui se pose la question
est ce qu'on a le droit de considérer
cette quantité infinie cette somme
infini qui a paris si bien pour
comprendre ce qu'il ya derrière tout ça
je vais me permettre d'être un petit peu
plus loin dans la formalisation des
nombreux paix a dit qu eto dénombre 2
indiqué dans ce cas en faisant un
parallèle avec l'épisode 2 avec le
paradoxe de zénon où on a vu que 0,9 9,9
à l'infini était défini comme la somme
infinie de 0,9 point 0,09 et ainsi de
suite jusqu'à l'infini
on avait dit que cette somme infinie
était égal à 1 parce qu'elle se
rapprochait indéfiniment près de 1 ou
plus exactement parce que lorsque l'on
calcule la soustraction 1 - 9 fini de
neuf n'obtiendront qui est très très
proche de zéro et plus on rajoute de 9
plus le nombre qu'on obtient qui va
tirer la gueule 0000 avec un plus ce
moment là va être proche de zéro et en
fait derrière tous les raisonnements il
y à cette idée selon laquelle un nombre
qui commence par 000 euros avec beaucoup
de zéros est un nom qui est très proche
de zéro on peut changer les règles du
jeu un petit peu et en fait il est utile
de changer les règles du jeu autant
lorsqu'on essaie d'étudier de l'algèbre
de faire de l'arithmétique
on essaie de voir qu'est-ce qui est
divisible par quoi il peut avoir à être
intéressant de dire que un nom qui est
proche de zéro c'est un nom qui en fait
a beaucoup de zéros non pas à gauche
partant de la virgule mais à à droite en
partant de la virgule et dans ce cas son
calcul
1 plus 1 1 avec un infini de 1
je veux obtenir 1 0 0 0 0 avec un grand
nombre de zéro mais un nombre fini 2 0
et là en topologie paix a dit qu on dit
que ce nombre est très proche de zéro
parce qu'il a beaucoup de zéros à droite
c'est une autre façon de penser
distance leçon de proximité et le jour
on s'est rendu compte qu'en fait il ya
plusieurs façons de décrire la proximité
entre différents objets et le jour où on
a complètement révolutionné notre
compréhension de des mathématiques et
plus précisément de l'analyse ça c'était
vers début du 20e siècle
et là on voit que plus on rajoute 2 1
plus lorsque l'on fait ce nombre +11 on
a un nombre qui contient beaucoup de
zéros à droite
or faire le nombre avec beaucoup de 1
plus 1
c'est aussi faire ses mains avec
beaucoup de 1 - - 1
et ça ça correspond à décrire la
distance entre le nombre et caen 2 1 et
-1 et donc en topologie paix indique
cette distance là elle tend vers zéro
parce que le nombre de zéros à droite de
la soustraction a de plus en plus de 0 à
droite et du coup comme un tueur
approche de plus en plus de -1 plus on
rajoute 2 1
on se permet de dire que la limite parce
qu'il ya une infinité de 1 sur la gauche
il cette limite là va être égal à -1
sur ce sujet je vous invite vraiment
aller voir ce superbe vidéo de free blue
one world qui parle de la merde on
invente des nouvelles mathématiques en
prenant cet exemple de la somme des deux
puissances n elle espère que vous avez
aimé cet épisode alors c'était un peu
plus chargé que d'habitude et tellement
de trucs incroyables à dire sur ces
séries divergentes pour aller un peu
plus loin notamment sur la fonction état
de riemann qui vend depuis incroyable
je vous invite vraiment aller voir
l'épisode de geely sur l'hypothèse de
riemann ou si vous voulez aller un petit
peu plus loin dans les calculs et les
nerfs aussi avec les nombres premiers
je voudrais aller voir la superbe vidéo
de gateway building banana qui par
contre a été roulé en savoir plus sur
les séries divergentes en général je
vous conseille l'excellent blog nos
sciences étonnante qui a réécrit
d'autres billets après son premier
billet qui vont de plus en plus loin
qu'ils sont de plus en plus précis sur
la formalisation de la saison et pour
les plus courageux il ya ressource
incontournable sur les semailles divers
l'on sait le billet de blog de terrance
taous le médaille fields qui explique
beaucoup plus de choses que je
et qui surtout qu'on prend beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
mieux la prochaine fois on va parler
d'un truc incroyable que j'ai découvert
récemment qui est le problème des
maisons numérotées de ramanujan le
problème est le suivant vous avez un
nombre fini de maisons qui sont
numérotées 1 2 3 400 piège et on sait
qu'il existe une maison tels que la
somme des numéros des maisons à gauche
de la maison est égale à la somme des
numéros à sa droite
on sait aussi qu'il ya entre 50 et 500
maisons au total la question c'est quel
est le nombre exact de prison enfin il
ya plusieurs d'entre vous qui semble
vouloir montrer moi j'ai vraiment envie
de rencontres occident vous propose de
remplir un google forme qui va être
quelque part à l'écran et dans les
descriptions pour que vous me donniez
poésie mêlée puis votre lieu de
résidence pour que l'on puisse organiser
de petites sorties autour d'une bière
par contre j'ai vraiment pas envie que
ça devienne pas une fois on ne puisse
pas parler tranquillement populaire du
coup vous proposera une point de
retrouver trois cadres autour d'une
bière si vous avez aimé cet épisode
penser à le lac est le commentaire de
partage et pensez à vous abonner pour ne
pas manquer les futurs épisodes merci a
tous peur pour leurs dons et j'espère
que vous verrez la prochaine fois un
plus de plus 3 + 4 + 1 + 6 comme ça
jusqu'à l'infini est égal à - 1 12e je
conçois parfaitement que l'on puisse ne
pas être d'accord avec simple entente
elle cette somme a fini devrait valoir
la fiq
mais si on se force à lui attribuer une
valeur la façon la plus naturelle de
faire c'est de prolonger la fonction
état qui peut pas donner autre chose que
moins associés